New York announced the opening of Mork
ovid 19 testing sites on Friday
hospitalizations there are down but
given as many as one of every four
carriers don't show symptoms medical
experts say knowing who has had the
disease is crucial to knowing who can
safely go back to work in order to
tackle the spread of the outbreak we
also need to test for people who may
have been exposed previously and now
have antibodies these types of tests
called serology tests will be the next
step in battling this virus we have now
completed more than 3.5 million tests by
far the most anywhere in the world
despite the president's claims the CDC
has been slow to deliver on the
administration's earlier promises of
more test kits and now he's telling
state governors it's their
responsibility
this Indiana lab responded to a plea for
help from the city of New York and is
ramping up production to provide 50,000
kits a week we've been discussing
everything from logistics of how to get
our kits there to how many cases they
would like to purchase on an ongoing
basis and even more so into how can they
do it themselves in neighboring New
Jersey Rutgers University has gotten
approval for a saliva test that could be
scaled up quickly and mailed directly to
people's homes the United States is
currently testing just under a hundred
and fifty thousand people per day for
the corona virus but experts say
millions of tests per day will be needed
to reopen the country safely and New
York's governor insists that can't be
done without the help of the federal
government especially given some of the
chemicals needed for the tests come from
China the federal government has passed
three bills to address this crisis of
those three bills the state governments
have gotten precisely zero zilch nada in
unrestricted aid but pressure to get
people back to work is mounting and the
president tweeted that Cuomo should stop
complaining and start acting Cuomo calls
the president's strategy passing the
buck without passing the bucks
Kristin salumi al Jazeera
New York